c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
seraient les bienvenues sur france one
qui a trait à la une ce soir un homme à
l'honneur l'architecte burkinabè francis
kéré il est le premier africain à
recevoir le prix pritzker la plus haute
distinction du monde de l' architecture
connue pour ses réalisations
respectueuse de l'environnement il est
notre invité ce soir
là les tresses de dizaines de
camerounais bloqués en ukraine leurs
multiples appels alors aux autorités
pour les faire évacuer n'ont rien donné
étudiants travailleurs femmes et enfants
se terrent dans les abris pour échapper
aux bombardements et leur famille au
cameroun sont très inquiètes reportage à
suivre
le manque d'eau touche principalement
des plus démunis au cap en afrique du
sud ce sont les quartiers les plus
pauvres qui en pâtissent vous verrez que
cette pénurie d'eau n'est pas que la
conséquence de la sécheresse elle est
aussi due à la vétusté des
infrastructures
[Musique]
c'est dans son petit village burkinabè
qu'il a fait ses premiers grands pas
d'architecte il a offert à gondo ses
premiers projets sa première école des
logements pour les enseignants une
bibliothèque un lycée un atelier de
formation et surtout un savoir faire et
des techniques de construction francis
kéré reconnu pour ses réalisations
durables respectueuses de
l'environnement a été consacrée à l'âge
de 57 ans par la plus haute distinction
du monde de l' architecture le prix
pritzker et il est notre invité ce soir
bonsoir
bonsoir madame merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous tout d'abord qu'avez-vous
ressenti lorsque vous avez appris que
vous étiez le lauréat du prix et prix de
scaer et qu'est-ce que ça va changer
pour vous
ben alors c'était inattendu à une grande
surprise un sentiment d'honneur et de
gran reconnaissance de ce que j'ai
toujours considéré comme quelque chose
de privé de la semaine c'est à dire
d'utiliser ce que j'ai appris à faire au
service déjà de chez moi
et bien sûr qu'est ce que ça veut dire
pour moi ça m'encourage beaucoup de
continuer à faire la recherche et à
travailler dans le sens que voilà j'ai
démarré des travaux
je suis je me sens très honoré je suis
heureux c'était inattendu
et voilà je vais continuer dans ce sens
alors vous êtes un pionnier dans la
construction durable notamment vous avez
réussi à
parce que vous avez réussi à conjuguer
modernité respect de l'environnement et
traditions comment vous avez fait pour
marier tout ça pour conjuguer tout ça
non au fait c'est simple c'est à dire
que j'ai toujours je me suis toujours
révolté de voir que des enfants sont
assis dans des salles de classe où il
fait très chaud oui et où il n'ya pas de
lumière dans un pays où ce panda il ya
la lumière du soleil est là et donc je
me suis dis qu'il faut utiliser ce qui
était un mandat pour créer des salles de
classe qui
procure un confort aux enseignants et
aux étudiants mais aussi qui inspire
voilà au fait laissez moi vous dire que
je voulais apporter de la beauté aux
plus démunis voilà et c'est en faisant
ainsi que des techniques sont venus
c'est à dire comment faire crier de
l'a26 lation passive comment créer en
toi qui soutient à la ventilation
passive et qui protège un même temps le
bâtiment contre les intérêts voilà c'est
ainsi que j'ai fait en modernisant la
terre ni ajoutant des agrégats c'est à
dire un peu de cima et créer des sortes
de blocs comprimés mais je ne m'arrête
pas simplement là au burkina faso il ya
de la latérite et je les utilise et en
la couplant et créer des façades qui
sont qui donne un sentiment d'une
modernité et voilà et qui inspire
j'utilise aussi du bois local
c'est-à-dire la lah lesquels bois
d'eucalyptus que j'ai tenus ce pour
crier des façades ou pour protéger les
parois canto le soleil et ainsi créer un
espace ombragé vient accueillant pour
les usagers alors sa façon de faire
alors vous raconter que justement ce n'a
pas toujours été facile de faire
accepter et de convaincre
sur des projets qui est et qui
réconcilie justement avec des matériaux
anciens naturel traditionnel pourquoi
c'est simple c'est à dire quand on vit
burkina on l'est on voit que beaucoup de
gens utilisent la terre mais vous savez
l'occident de ton par sa façon de faire
ou sa façon de dire que ce que ce que
nous possédons un primitif et que ça n'a
pas de valeur on fini par rejeter ce que
nous possédons c'est à dire de dire que
construire avec la terre c'est synonyme
de pauvreté mais je n'ai pas voulu
accepter cela j'ai voulu j'ai voulu
améliorer la terre et créer des bâtisses
qui inspire voilà et c'est ce que j'ai
fait et et il faut convaincre toujours
il faut convaincre il faut pas se
laisser
il faut pas se laisser
stoppée mais il faut prouver que ce que
nous avons peuvent constituer en
développement dans notre pays et j'ai
fait ça en utilisant de la terre pour
construire ma première école qui a
commencé à avoir de la visibilité ça m'a
permis de continuer aujourd'hui je me
trouve dans la position de construire
des pavillons de luxe aux états unis en
angleterre et un peu partout alors vous
vous dites il faut convaincre si vous
deviez convaincre nos téléspectateurs
africains et mayer de revenir vers ses
matériaux naturels et de construire
durable que leur diriez vous
ben c'est simple si vous continuez à
utiliser des matériaux qui ne viennent
pas du ch vous les ressources vont
disparaître on voyait si vous utilisez
ce que vous avez et vous profiter de
cela pour améliorer les savoir-faire
l'eau le local c'est-à-dire que vous
apportez une fierté nous apporter une
reconnaissance à ce que nous possédons
et c'est ça qui va nous faire avancer
c'est ça qui va nous faire nous
développer voilà ce sont des techniques
anciennes que nous connaissons tous sont
des techniques qui travaillent avec eux
avec avec les intempéries et qui
résistent et en même temps on normand la
fierté locale c'est à dire les gens se
sentent valoriser leur savoir-faire pris
au sérieux c'est tout ce que j'avais
fait tout simple
merci beaucoup en tout cas francis kéré
d'avoir accepté notre invitation je
rappelle que vous êtes le lauréat du
prix pritzker
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
merci beaucoup merci madame
ils sont des dizaines de camerounais à
être encore bloquée en ukraine sans
aucune perspective d'évacuation des
étudiants des travailleurs mais surtout
des familles avec femme et enfants ils
sont contraints de se terrer dans des
abris principalement à kiev et à kharkiv
pourra échapper aux bombardements leurs
nombreux appels à l'aide aux autorités
camerounaises sont restées sans réponse
reportage de tony magi stéphanois est
très dur pour vous tous mais
tout ce qu'on veut maintenant c'est de
centimes grâce à des vidéos tournées
avec leur téléphone portable
des dizaines de ressortissants
camerounais comme adrien un marin de 35
ans arrivé en ukraine il y a dix ans
témoignent de leur quotidien difficile
depuis le début de l'offensive russe on
a la chance de pouvoir fêter un groupe
qu'on a acheté du riz
la farine donc déjà n'a plus de temps
dans la ville ni plus ni moins une fois
par jour
comprenant des enfants plus lettrés
complètement des familles et de nombreux
étudiants camerounais qui disent avoir
sollicité l'aide de leurs gouvernements
afin d'être évacués ils n'ont reçu en
retour que ce simple communiqué les
appelant à la prudence et à suivre les
instructions des autorités ukrainiennes
aucun rapatriement n'a eu lieu nous
avons appelé nous avons fait tout ce qui
était possible avec les ambassades les
autorités mais tout ce qu'ils nous
disent c'est d'attendre attendre
attendre et on attend mais on n'a pas de
nourriture on n'a pas d'eau on a très
peur à 5000 km de là dont ces banlieue
de douala la famille d'adrien vie dans
la tourmente parti en europe où une vie
meilleure le jeune homme subvenait aux
besoins de la famille et prenez en
charge les frais de santé de son père
atteint de la maladie de parkinson
regardez les informations ont discuté
avec leur fils yoann zap est devenu le
seul moyen d'espérer pour ses parents
espérer que les autorités prennent des
mesures concrètes pour évacuer les
ressortissants quoi aussi en ukraine
quand tu envoies ton enfant d'aller
chercher pouvait ni te soutenir et guile
et qu'il est en guerre qu'est ce que tu
peux ressentir
nous sommes en l'air depuis ils
s'étaient le grand soutien de la famille
celui qui faisait presque tout pour nous
vraiment nous supplions
les ong les organisations
humanitaires et le gouvernement
camerounais de vous sortir nos enfants
de ces de ce pétrin depuis que la russie
a lancé le 24 février une attaque contre
l'ukraine deux ressortissants
camerounais sont décédés
on manque d'eau en afrique du sud et
pourtant il ne s'agit pas forcément de
sécheresse les infrastructures vétustes
sont aussi parfois responsables de
nombreuses coupures d'eau et ce sont les
quartiers les plus défavorisés qui en
pâtissent le plus scheer licite beau
c'est devenu la routine pour des
milliers d'habitants du cap tous les
matins il cherche des robinets chez eux
l'eau ne coule plus
on n'a pas d'autre choix que de se lever
le matin à essayer de remplir nos sauts
le manque d'eau est un problème
récurrent il y a quatre ans la ville a
connu une grande sécheresse sur ces
images l'un des grands réservoirs de la
ville à l'époque aujourd'hui ce même
réservoir est plein et pourtant l'eau
n'arrive pas dans certains quartiers
défavorisés
c'est pire qu'à l'époque parce qu'à
l'époque on savait qu'on avait un
problème d'eau maintenant il y à de
l'eau et nous le savons c'est pire que
pendant la sécheresse
parmi les raisons de cette crise un
défaut de planification le nombre
d'habitants a doublé en 25 ans mais les
réserves n'ont pas suivi les
canalisations sont vétustes la ville
elle accuse les habitants installés
illégalement dans certains endroits
nineteen pendant la pandémie dix-sept
nouveaux bidonvilles sont sortis de
terre dans notre ville
et on attend de la ville qu'elles
amènent l'eau l'électricité et des
égouts dans ces bidonvilles
c'est difficile à faire tafer compte
tous les bidonvilles en question ont été
mises en place par des habitants ayant
perdu leur travail et logement pendant
le confinement les pénuries d'eau vont
bien au delà et concerne une trentaine
de quartiers de la ville
et comme chaque année en vous propose le
portrait du lauréat du prix challenge ap
afrique 1 cette année c'est l'ivoirienne
christelle quam qui a remporté la
sixième édition avec sa plateforme
prenez les feuilles une plateforme qui
permet l'accès aux programmes scolaires
sous le format de résumer de cours par
chapitre et par matière une aide
précieuse pour certains élèves
reportages d'anna ferjani damien koffi
et samuel bernard
un lycée de la commune de yopougon à
abidjan christelle quoi mais son équipe
sont venus présenter leur plateforme
éducative prenait les feuilles dans
cette classe d'âge son leitmotiv 100 %
de réussite au bac pour ceux qui
utiliseront son application de révision
a tout fait pour compiler
de préparation pour vous si la plupart
de ces élèves ont déjà un smartphone
il s'agit d'en faire enfin un outil
pédagogique mais ça ne sait si vous
l'avez déjà à portée de main c'est
chargé jusqu'à application puisque c'est
gratuit à télécharger
téléchargez vos deux mois et puis testé
l'application découvrez là et vous allez
voir comment ça va vous aider en fait
d'un jeune âge aujourd'hui 6000 élèves
utilisent régulièrement la plateforme en
ligne l'application lancée début mars
compte elle presque deux mille
téléchargements jean-françois élèves de
terminale est abonné depuis septembre en
plat j'ai le devoir du lycée classique
d'abidjan et si je me rends compte que
je ne comprends pas bien et je ne suis
pas sûr de mes résultats je reviens sur
le site et j'étais chars la correction
selon lui ces résultats se sont
sensiblement améliorées pour la mère de
jean françois il a surtout pu rattraper
le retard accumulé en raison de la crise
sanitaire et dès qu'elle est tombée sur
les sticks il était vraiment content
parce qu'il avait plusieurs exercices
qui pouvait faire
à tout moment c'est face au constat d'un
taux de réussite de la peine 40 % à
l'échelle nationale que christelle a eu
l'idée de ce projet selon elle cette
plateforme permet aussi de résorber
certaines inégalités lui c'est possible
pour un ménage
faiblement instruit de permettre à cette
nouvelle génération d'élèves d'accéder
quand même d'avoir les mêmes droits que
d'autres en fonction des ouvrages juste
à partir de leur téléphone portable
prenez les feuilles ambitionne de
toucher un maximum d'élèves au delà des
frontières ivoiriennes le lancement
d'une plateforme au sénégal est prévu
pour l'horizon 2025
et on vous parle du prix à des trophées
de l'étranger l'une des lauréates
claudia castellano vie à essoyes tiny
anciennement swaziland elle travaille
dans l'agriculture organique elle a
monté une société qui fabrique des
sauces pimentées ex porte partout dans
le monde elle a été récompensée par le
ministère des affaires étrangères
français pour son engagement à la fois
social et environnemental reportage de
caroline dumay et stéphane carstens
elle est tombée amoureuse de ce petit
royaume montagneux et rural claudia a
quitté définitivement sa colombie natale
en 2010 pour se lancer dans la
commercialisation des piments en est
soit signé elle fait travailler une
soixantaine d'agriculteurs
d'agricultrice plus tôt car 80% de ses
fournisseurs sont des femmes et encore
ça s'était très patriarcale mais je me
suis rendu compte très tôt que les
femmes sont les piliers de la société
c'est un produit facile à cultiver dont
le prix sur le marché est intéressant à
l aps des n'était
maintenant j'aide les plus démunis et
j'ai même réussi à m'acheter une
gazinière
claudia ne pourrait pas travailler sans
ces femmes n'y sont ces deux ong qui
forme ses partenaires à la permaculture
l'agriculture biologique est encore peu
connue en niçois t
on à cette perception que l'agriculture
biologique est fait pour une certaine
classe sociale
c'est en partie dû au fait que les
produits sont chers mais plus on aura de
producteurs les plus les prix seront
abordables
une fois rassemblés les piments sont
aussi mises en bouteille en est soit
signé
claudia une vingtaine d'employés ici
toutes les sauces sont faites à la main
devant une production qui a quasiment
doublé en deux ans restait artisanale
est un défi de taille parce qu'il ya
beaucoup plus passant le monde
maintenant qu'ils sont qui veulent
savoir d'où les produits qu'ils
consomment d'où il vient qui fait mon
produit est ce qu'il est un produit qui
est propre alors je pense que c'est
partie de black mamba ne va pas jamais
changé même si on doit mécanisée
certains procès
pouvoir agrandir
l'agriculture biologique africaine est
en plein essor les sauces de black mamba
sont exportés en asie en europe et aux
états unis
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'afrique merci aux équipes en régie
merci à notre chef d'édition célia
karacena merci à nos correspondants sans
qui ce journal ne pourrait pas se faire
et merci à vous de nous être fidèles
restés avec nous d'info continue sur
france 2
[Musique]